Yeah, let's do this.
>> All right, go ahead and ask me your
question.
All right.
What's your first question?
So, Exodus 20, it begins
God spoke all these words saying, "I the
Lord am your God who brought you out of
the land of Egypt, the house of bondage.
Mhm. You shall have no other gods
besides me.
You shall not make for yourself a
sculpted image or any likeness of what
is in the heavens above or on the earth
below
>> Yeah. or waters under the sea.
Yeah, okay.
So, what's your interpretation of that?
That you can't have false gods and
goddesses that you worship.
Okay.
So, when they worship King Messiah,
serve him, is he a false god?
Uh well, Messiah hasn't come yet. No, I
didn't ask you that because in Daniel 7,
it says when he comes, all nations must
serve him. Are they now committing
idolatry?
No. You sure?
Are you Do you worship your boss when
you go to work?
My boss is not God in the flesh, so
don't ask me a silly question like that.
I'm asking you about King Messiah in
Daniel 7.
>> I serve someone in the context of serve
Are we going to go Okay, now you know
what? Now I got to really embarrass you.
Go to now Psalm 72 because you see I
thought I could be you I'm using the
same word here, avad. Yishtahavah. Hold
on. Are you talking over me or do you
want me to answer your question?
I'm going to go ahead. Okay, in the
verse you quoted, the words for serve,
avad, and bow down is yishtahavah.
Now, I'm going to show you those two
words used of Messiah. Go to Psalm 72
because I'm sick of playing your game.
Go to Psalm 72.
The same words, bow down and worship
>> [clears throat]
>> and serve. The same words used in Exodus
20 that you're playing games with me.
Avad, yishtahavah, shachah. Same Hebrew
words. Go to Psalm 72.
Read verse one. It's talking about who
here?
Oh, Solomon. Oh, David now. Start at the
top. It's about who?
Solomon. No, reread the Well,
Okay, let's go with Solomon. It's about
the king's son. It's a Psalm of Solomon
and it's not about the son of the king,
right?
Yeah. Okay. Now, your versification may
be different cuz in the Tanakh I didn't
get this far. I don't know, dude. I
don't care how far you went, dude. Stop
your whining, dude. This is your Tanakh.
Stop whining and read your scripture.
Okay, stop with the whining.
Psalm 72
Now, you may have a different
versification. My verse one may be your
verse two. Read from verse
eight all the way to 12.
I can't we start at verse one to go to
12? Dude, you want to spend two hours
reading the entire thing? My pleasure.
But read verse eight to 12.
>> so far so Can you read verse eight to 12
or I'm going to hang up on you cuz now
you're being silly. Read eight to 12.
Uh
may he rule from sea to sea, from the
rivers to the ends of the earth.
Let desert dwellers kneel before him.
And his enemies lick the dust. Mhm. Uh
let kings of Tarshish and the islands
pay tribute. Kings of Sheba and Seba
offer gifts. Let all kings bow to him
and all Do what to him?
Bow to him. You know what the word is?
Bow. The very word you just quoted in
Exodus 20, you're not to bow down to
anything besides God.
Yeah. So, why are they bowing to the
king?
CUZ HE'S THE KING.
OH, SO BOWING TO A KING is not idolatry.
Mhm,
interesting. Uh it can be.
Okay, so what are you trying to prove
now cuz you're all over the place. Are
you saying
bowing down to any besides God is sin?
Okay, well now they're bowing to the
king. Is that sin?
Well, he's the Messiah, so
>> Oh, so Messiah will be worshipped. So
why are you arguing when I just spent
>> they're just bowing to him like paying
respect. I don't think they're like You
sure about that? God worship. You sure?
>> I'm not This is Psalm 72. I haven't even
read Psalms 72.
>> Okay, so then brother, can I ask you
something? Why are you asking me
questions when I go to give you an
answer, you whine and complain. WELL, I
WOULDN'T BEEN THERE. I DIDN'T GET THERE.
I wouldn't So then why you asking
>> feel like when you're talking about a
book, especially one with like 4,000
pages, you should at least know like So
then that Why don't you practice what
you preach and don't ask me questions
that you're not ready for the answers
cuz did I contact you or you contacted
me?
Uh I contacted you. Okay, so now that
I'm answering
>> You're making more money off me than I
am off you though. Really? So wait, when
Rabbi Singer, that makes money off
of YouTube and being monetized and scums
like you pay him. So you're saying he's
a because he's making money off of
stupid people like you? Who said those?
I never said that.
>> No, no, I'm asking cuz you just attacked
me. See the cheap shot? Now you're
exposing yourself as a dog because you
just took a cheap shot. Respect yourself
or I'm going to insult you.
Okay, did I contact you or you you
contacted me?
I contacted you. Which means you thought
you knew enough to then in dialogue with
me. So then why are you not whining when
you're getting schooled? You want to end
it, you can, but it's your I didn't
contact you, you contacted me. You
disrespected my Lord the way you spoke.
What did I say? You said, "Hey, uh talk
about your God, lowercase G, Jesus." And
you know that's an insult to Christians
when you when you talk about Jesus this
way.
When I say Jesus is your God that's
Yeah, your God, lowercase G, by mockery.
Weren't you mocking?
No, that's Don't lie. God knows your
heart. You're going to answer before
God.
Okay, I wasn't mocking.
To tell a Christian that you're going to
dialogue about your God, lowercase G,
Jesus, you know you're offending
Christians. You're coming off
offensively.
Uh well, I didn't know that.
>> Now you know. Do you want to continue
talking about worship or do you want to
end the conversation?
>> I just say, "Let's talk about Jesus." if
I have a conversation with a Christian?
I shouldn't say your God.
You don't say your God, lowercase G.
Okay, but so it's for the future, just
don't say your God, just say, "Let's
talk about Jesus." No, you When we don't
call Jesus a lowercase G, lowercase G
meaning that he's a god, a false god.
That's what you said. Don't Dude, I'm
not I wasn't born yesterday, I was born
the day before.
So if you want people to respect you and
not be antagonistic towards you, you
don't come off Someone I don't even know
who you are. Hey, I heard you want to
talk to a Jew. I want to you know, talk
about your God, lowercase G, Jesus.
You're insulting me and you're coming
off a But that's okay, put it aside. Now
you learn. All right, I'm sorry, but
Okay, that's okay. Do you now want to
continue talk about worship?
I didn't mean to insult you, so can I
explain my logic? No, uh hold on. What
are you really talking about right now?
I showed you a passage that the king is
worshiped. You say, "I don't know
enough." So are we wasting time? What do
you Because I got other things to talk
to, but anything I show you, you're
going to say, "I'm not I haven't gotten
there."
I wanted to give you verses, but you
didn't want to go over them. I just did.
I see it's recorded, you're lying. Dude,
hey. Oh, wait, wait. Listen. DID YOU NOT
GIVE ME EXODUS 20? DID I NOT just go
over it?
That was like Yeah. Okay, so why are you
falsely slandering saying I didn't want
to go over it? So number one, I am going
over your verses, so I just addressed
it, but did you see your responses? I
haven't been to Psalms yet, so how am I
going to win? If I quote a book you
haven't read, well, I haven't been
there. So give me your second question.
Okay.
So, I'm not going to win either way cuz
when I quote another book, I haven't
been there. Okay.
I mean, probably. I'll be honest with
you. I've only read the Second Kings.
I'm getting Okay, so then why are you
going to ask me a question that if I go
to a book you haven't read, you're going
to say, "Well, I haven't gotten there."
So, are you So, are we wasting time?
Cuz when I quote a verse, you're going
to say, "Brother, I haven't read Psalm
72." Or I haven't read Isaiah 9. Uh
okay, so then am I wasting time?
>> Well, is there anything that proves it
like in Kings or Second Kings?
>> King prove what?
Prove what? What are you looking for
proof?
>> do you have any verses from Samuel or do
you have any verses Regarding what? Be
specific. I don't know what you're
asking me. What am I What are you
looking for? The Trinity. What we're
talking about the Trinity. So, you went
Wait, when I went through Genesis and I
showed you the angel of the Lord,
that's not the Tanakh?
Exodus 23, that's not the Tanakh? You
admitted when I quoted Exodus 23:20,
yeah, the angel is God sending himself
as an angel who's God. So, what else you
want me to prove? You admitted it.
Yeah, I mean And you admitted that the
man on Earth, that's God on Earth as a
man in the form of an angel.
But now go to Genesis 16. Since you want
to go to Genesis Stick in Genesis. Go to
Genesis 16.
Hold on a second.
I thought we were going to do my verse.
Oh, but you you just told me prove the
Trinity from the Tanakh.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay, I'm confused. What do you want me
to do? Okay, give me your verse.
Um
>> Okay.
So, at verse 15 in Deuteronomy 4
Yeah, I know what you're [clears throat]
going to quote. You didn't see no form
or shape, right?
For your own sake, therefore, be most
careful since you saw no shape when the
Lord your God spoke to you at Horeb out
of the fire. You heard I said that's
what it's going to say, right?
Huh?
Did you know I said I know what you're
going to quote? Deuteronomy 4:15, the
Israelites didn't see no shape or form,
right?
I'm not I'm not done yet. Okay, but I
was I was right. That's what you're
quoting, right? That's what I'm saying.
Just so far that this I know where
you're going. Okay, now finish it cuz
now he's going to backfire against you.
Go ahead.
Uh
for your own sake, therefore, be most
careful since you saw no shape when the
Lord your God spoke to you at Horeb
out of the fire, not to act wickedly and
make for yourselves a sculpted image in
any likeness whatever the form of a man
or a woman,
the form of any beast on the earth,
the form of any winged
bird that flies in the sky, the form of
anything that creeps on the ground, the
form of any fish that is in the water
below the earth, and when you look up to
the sky, behold the sun, the moon, and
the stars, the whole heavenly host, you
must not be lured to bow down to them or
serve
Okay. the Lord your God allotted to the
other peoples everywhere under the
heaven, but you the Lord
but you the Lord took and brought out of
Egypt that iron blast furnace to be his
very own people as is now the case.
Okay, so do you want me to address you
now?
What's your interpretation of all that?
Uh go to Numbers 12 and read verses 5 to
8.
But what's your interpretation of what I
just said?
>> Go to Numbers 12 for the answer, dude.
Don't tell me how to answer you. I'm
answering you. Go to Numbers 12:5-8.
Don't be a coward. I know you're scared.
Read it.
Numbers 12 verses 5 to 8.
Don't tell me how to answer you. I'm
answering you.
Okay, then.
Okay, which one? Numbers 12:5-8.
Oh, my goodness.
Read 5 to 8.
Uh the Lord came down in a pillar of
cloud, stopped at the entrance of the
tents and called out Aaron and Miriam.
The two of them came forward and he
said, "Hear these my words. When a
prophet of the Lord arises among you, I
make myself known to him in a vision. I
speak with him in a dream.
Not so with my servant Moshe. He is
trusted throughout my household. With
him I speak mouth to mouth, plainly and
not in riddles, and he beholds the
likeness of the Lord."
>> He beholds what?
The likeness of the Lord. So, wait. Even
though Israel did not see a likeness or
a form, God showed his form and likeness
to Moshe.
Mhm.
So, are you saying that your Tanakh
contradicts itself because in
Deuteronomy 4, God speaking to the
nation, when God came in a cloud, you
didn't see a likeness or a shape. But,
then he says to Moshe
and to Aaron and Miriam, his sister,
"Moses speaks to me face to face and he
sees my likeness, my shape."
Yeah.
So, are you saying God can't appear in a
shape, or he can, but he only allows
some people to see it?
Only Moshe, it says right here. Okay,
good. So, then when God appeared as a
man to Abraham, did Abraham see God in
the form of a man?
Uh Genesis 18. you want to go over it
again?
I mean, not really, dude. Okay, so So,
you see, right? God does appear. God can
appear in a shape and a form, even as a
man, right?
I mean, sure, yeah. Sure, yeah. Okay,
now go to Isaiah 6.
Wait, hold on. Wait, wait, wait. No,
dude, hold on. Let me answer the
question. Go to Isaiah 6.
And don't tell me I haven't gotten that
far. You asked me a question, I'm
answering. Go to Isaiah 6.
When you get there, let me know. Read
verses 1 to 5.
Isaiah 6 Verses 1 to 5. Yeah. Read it
slowly and loudly.
In the year that the king
Uzziah died, I beheld my Lord seated on
high and lofty throne, and the skirts of
his robe Okay. One more time, read verse
1, cuz I want it to sink in by the power
of the Holy Spirit. Read it again. In
the year that King Uzziah died, I did
what?
I beheld my Lord seated on a high and
lofty throne. So, he saw God on a
throne?
Yeah. Okay. And not only on a throne,
but his God wearing a robe. Keep going.
Seraphs stood in attendance on him. Each
of them had six wings. With two he
covered his face, with two he covered
his legs, and with two he would fly.
And one would call to the other, "Holy,
holy, holy is Lord of hosts his presence
fills all the earth."
The doorposts would shake at the sound
of the one who called and the house kept
filling with smoke. I cried, Slowly.
You're reading too fast. Now read keep
reading.
"Woe is me, I am lost for I am a man of
unclean lips and I live among a people
of unclean lips. Yet my own eyes have
beholden the king Lord of hosts." I
don't think you read that carefully. My
own eyes my physical eyes saw who?
"The king Lord of hosts." So wait, I
thought Deuteronomy 4:15 which you
quoted shows that God will not and
cannot appear in a visible shape or
likeness that people can see, but Isaiah
says my physical eye sees God on a
throne in a physical shape wearing a
robe. God says to him Aaron and Miriam,
"Moses sees my likeness, my form." And
God appeared as a man to Abraham and
they all saw God in a shape or form.
Mhm.
So what are you trying to prove from
Deuteronomy 4?
Uh
it's what it I prove what it says like
it says not to worship anything in the
form of anything especially a man or a
woman especially
>> Oh so wait, when when
Moses sees God in a shape and form and
worships him or Isaiah sees God in a
shape and form and worships him or
Abraham sees God in human shape and
worships him they're violating the 10
Commandments?
Uh no. Okay. So that means again, you
need to stop being brainwashed by your
rabbis and ask the spirit to guide you
to understand what these passages mean.
Moreover, I want to ask you a question.
Are you certain that God is against
having a shape or an image that you bow
to? Are you certain?
Yeah. You certain?
That's what it says in the book. Okay,
go to Exodus 25. All right, okay. Go to
Ex- Go to Exodus 25. Let's see how
certain you are. Exodus 25:18-22.
Exodus 25:18-22.
Your same Tanakh. I'm not quoting New
Testament.
What does God have Moses fashion? Keep
reading.
What was verse?
>> Exodus 25:18-22.
Make two cherubim of gold and make them
of hammered work. Make what of gold?
>> [clears throat]
>> Cherubim. So wait, God is telling Moses
make an image of things in heaven,
cherubim?
Yeah. Oh, good. Keep reading.
At the two ends of the
Make them of hammered work at the two
ends of the cover. Make one cherub at
one end and the other cherub at the
other end of one piece with the cover
shall you make the cherubim at its two
ends.
The cherubim shall have their wings
spread out above shielding the cover
with their wings. They shall confront
each other, the faces of the cherubim
being turned toward the cover.
Place the cover on top of the ark after
depositing inside the ark the pact that
I will give you. There I will meet with
you and I will impart to you from above
the cover from between the two cherubim
that are on top of the ark of the pact.
Okay, [clears throat] so
>> command you concerning the issue of
people. Okay, you see well brother, you
don't need to read the entire chapter.
God told Moses Actually you should but
okay. Really? You sure if I read the
entire chapter you're going to end up
being embarrassed. So don't be a smart
alec. Listen.
God told Moses fashion cherubim,
creatures in heaven, overlay them with
gold and their wings stretched out
on the ark.
But I thought you shouldn't have any
image of anything in heaven, on earth,
beneath the earth or the seas below. Not
only that, now go to Joshua 7. Joshua Go
to Joshua 7.
Okay, we'll talk about it when you read
Joshua 7:6 which you've read.
I'm going to hang up on you if you don't
go to Joshua 7:6.
You are literally a charlatan. Okay, I
know, I know, yeah, I know. Yeah, I'm a
charlatan. Go to Joshua 7 you coward,
let's see. Verse 6. Did this Did Did
>> Can you read Joshua 7:6 where Joshua
bowed to the ark?
Can you go to Joshua 7 before I
humiliate you?
>> [laughter]
>> You saw the manifestation?
You saw he manifested, right?
Thank the Lord Jesus, it's recorded.
YOU SAW HE MANIFESTED?
>> [screaming]
>> TELL ME THAT'S NOT DEMON POSSESSED.